[Music]
one year off housewives how do you feel
about it you know I think it was really
good to take a break and take a step
back it's been a crazy year you know I
have Heather dubrow's world and dr. mrs.
guinea pig podcast my youtube channel
Heather's closet our skincare line
consult beauty is been blowing up and
Terry and I just finished our second
book a diet book that'll be out next
year in 2018 so there's a lot of fun
that stuff going on and of course I
still keep in touch with the girls on
the show though we're always my friends
any chance we can get you back because I
feel like we need you back what do we
say to that max well you know what Bryce
Never Say Never
Real Housewives of Orange County was an
incredible experience for me five years
made great friends and had an amazing
experiences and quite honestly it was a
terrific platform for everything that
Terry and I have done and for our family
so I'm very very grateful and as for the
future Never Say Never
I think it's a bigger picture it's not
really about any one particular thing I
think it would just have to make sense
et catching up with former Real
Housewives of Orange County star hello
Dubrow and her daughter max at The
Whisky A Go Go in LA
[Applause]
max took the stage with Quiet Riot over
the weekend for a special performance
her late uncle Kevin Dubrow was the
band's lead singer she's fun and
talented and amazing and I all I said to
her was have fun cuz that's all it's
about it's it's a cool life experience
and just have fun and kill it
keeping the mom had on not the momager
had yeah no no yeah you know what my
what Ivan knows about my kids is that
they're mostly dabblers which is
completely fine with me all I care about
is that they're happy and lucky and
healthy happy lucky healthy that's it
[Music]
you
[Music]